**Susan Daniels**: It welcome back everyone, we are in day to afternoon final session and the focus of this last hour whoo the last hour of today is going to be the plan and manage quality, a lot of the today's this segments lecture is on tools and techniques that are used to.
**Susan Daniels**: Basically, manage quality so we'll be covering things like root cause analysis control charts interesting things like that.
**Susan Daniels**: Towards the end but before we can control that we have to plan for it so let's look at what's involved in planning and managing quality.
**Susan Daniels**: As you can see it's rather resource it's rather rich in the different kinds of tools and techniques that we use.
**Susan Daniels**: Benchmarking against our peers in the industry that's very much a common tool will talk about quality audits and different ways of verifying deliverables and how will actually control and get things back up to the quality that is expected.
**Susan Daniels**: So when we are talking about quality or talking about trying to meet expectations quality, by definition, is a thing a result meets the definition of an has the inherent characteristics required for it to qualify to be that, so let me give you an example.
**Susan Daniels**: There are different, there are characteristics of a cubic seer conan and characteristics of a diamond and having those inherent characteristics are meeting those qualifications, make it qualify, to be a diamond versus a cubic zero con is a common.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, when we're trying to build quality results and quality measures, we have to make sure that our products qualify and meet these different kinds of standards regulations and i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Come to be able to comply okay so.
**Susan Daniels**: Depending on your industry, you may have things that are very clearly articulated right very does your written into the law regulations, construction and.
**Susan Daniels**: Energy and health care and finance have many law that they have to comply with okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But there are also some kind of de facto regulation which are things that this is just the way the industry does it Okay, it says historical precedence and that's how.
**Susan Daniels**: it's become sort of expected to meet that that that regulation it's not written in the law, but it is widely accepted and expected.
**Susan Daniels**: So we use in project management, we have many standards and guys that we use for best practices right and that's what you're here to learn today, what are the best practices and standards for a project management professional.
**Susan Daniels**: If you're in the European theater or do international business then you're probably very familiar with the ISO series is the international standards to do commerce in the European Union.
**Susan Daniels**: So this slide is really to get you to pause and and recognize that there may be beyond just the requirements that you've collected.
**Susan Daniels**: For from the stakeholders to build this new change that the organization wants there may be a lot of regulations associated with it.
**Susan Daniels**: kind of this slide that reminds you when you're building your budget remember compliance, while this is the area in project management planning we focus on compliance.
**Susan Daniels**: So we're going to kind of fast forward and talk about starting the end in mind, this is the slide that says what we're.
**Susan Daniels**: we're doing here is we're trying to figure out how we're going to verify that our result is compliant.
**Susan Daniels**: OK, so the project management team is the one that verifies okay creates verified deliverables is simply means is verified to be compliant with the quality standards that are put associated with that work package okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The project team itself before it releases it to the end customer internally does a verification.
**Susan Daniels**: As the project manager it's not always your job to do that Okay, there are other parties in the company that are better positioned to do the verification of the word package that is meeting compliance.
**Susan Daniels**: But your job is to make sure that that occurs Okay, now it is the end customer okay That then is given these verified.
**Susan Daniels**: deliverables are these verified results, and they have the decision to accept or not accept okay it's sort of that check your work before you turn it in kind of thing, but it is still up to the customer to say if it meets expectations or not.
**Susan Daniels**: A lot of time is spent trying to determine how we are going to measure compliance Okay, how we are going to be able to prove assess and prove what measure and metrics we're going to use a lot of time is spent capturing documenting negotiating these.
**Susan Daniels**: And then, if it's not when it gets tries to get verified and it doesn't actually meet the measure, then it's up to us to implement the corrective action plan.
**Susan Daniels**: So we kind of set up the verification will occur, we are set up the meeting for it to be accepted by the.
**Susan Daniels**: The end user, we are the ones responsible for making sure there is a measure we may not set it we may not have.
**Susan Daniels**: The subject matter expertise to even begin to identify what the measure would be, but we need to know that there it's been developed agreed upon and set in place, and then, if you hear back that it didn't pass were the ones facilitate getting the corrective action.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes it's just getting the right people in the room and documenting the decisions.
**Susan Daniels**: So that's kind of our role when we're planning and managing.
**Susan Daniels**: Quality of course we are going to have a quality management plan and by now, you should know this is a memo an email a document that is sent to your stakeholders to your sponsors saying.
**Susan Daniels**: hey this is going to be my approach okay to defining quality measuring quality putting in the audits.
**Susan Daniels**: Putting in the verification the testing the performance reports that I want when I want them, who I want them from where i'm going to store them what the link is to go see where I would store them, it is your plan.
**Susan Daniels**: Every time you send one of these plans up to your sponsor they know they're dealing with a professional they know you've got to go forward and work your plan and they know that you thought it through broadly.
**Susan Daniels**: Now if you're looking for what all to put into your quality management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: There are reference documents, particularly in the sixth edition, the seventh edition may point to it Okay, but I know that it's it's well listed in the standards and guides.
**Susan Daniels**: On what goes into a quality management plan Okay, but the goal here is to affirm to your senior leadership your your sponsors that you know quality matters and that you are going to build into your project plan.
**Susan Daniels**: What you're going to assess when you're going to assess it and who you're going to hold accountable for the House assessments to be done Okay, the whole fact that you have a quality management plan is a differentiator from many project managers out there in the field today.
**Susan Daniels**: I want you to have this kind of embedded into your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your psyche, if you will, that quality always cost okay now What do I mean by that excuse me.
**Susan Daniels**: You can spend money on your project either proactively or as a consequence of failure, you can send it as a preventative measure.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, that you are going to train the staff, the way they need to be trained you're going to invest in the right quality equipment you're going to invest in the right caliber of talent that you need.
**Susan Daniels**: You are going to invest in inspecting and auditing, as you need okay you're going to invest in and bake into your project quad the cost of quality or.
**Susan Daniels**: If you don't you may have to pay for it on the back end through lost business scrap rework liability suits Okay, but either way you're going to pay for either high quality and having the quality built in or pay for the fact that it wasn't quality.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm just um.
**Susan Daniels**: So.
**Susan Daniels**: How do we make sure that we're delivering quality well it gets back to doing the right kinds of quality metrics you don't have to be the subject matter expert on it, but you do have to understand.
**Susan Daniels**: Every work package which is going to ultimately be put together for the final result okay has to have some measure of quality okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And the people doing the work our closest and in the best position oftentimes to recommend how to assess and how to evaluate their work, they can point to standards and.
**Susan Daniels**: Regulations, they can point to what is kind of de facto the norm for this organization, you can benchmark it against external but there has to be some way to go, yes, this is quality, and that is put into your work breakdown dictionary agreement.
**Susan Daniels**: here's the value of it let's say you negotiate with a supervisor of a department who's accountable for some result for you right.
**Susan Daniels**: And you negotiate and you've kind of done all of your estimating based upon using super Sally the subject matter expert.
**Susan Daniels**: But super Sally recognizes her worth and gets another job in the meantime, and you, instead of getting super Sally get well we'll call it lazy Larry no slight intended to any larry's just saying it's an alliteration so we get the lazy guy right.
**Susan Daniels**: Again, no offense to larry's so we get the lazy guy instead now lazy guy does less than quality work, and I mean let's even say that it is very poor performance.
**Susan Daniels**: If you don't have in your your agreement with that accountable party how you're going to evaluate the quality of the work.
**Susan Daniels**: You can't just have a gut check you can't just say this looks bad I don't think this is good enough or you're hearing that it's not good enough from other parties who are on the receiving end of it.
**Susan Daniels**: you're not empowered okay to go back to the accountable party or even back to the lazy you employee and say expectations were set here, this is the measure of quality, I am expect this to be rectified.
**Susan Daniels**: So is extremely important as a project manager to protect yourself from that lazy poor performance happening to you negotiated a team, not the D team okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But if you empower yourself, by putting these measures and these quality metrics into your agreements from the beginning, you are in solid ground, not only for.
**Susan Daniels**: yourself, but for the person you go to to say hey i'm lazy employee, this is the quality metric that I negotiated it needs to meet expectations do it over right.
**Susan Daniels**: And it's well documented and black and white so help yourself help your accountable person to be able to address poor quality submissions.
**Susan Daniels**: But with That being said, quality metrics often need to have a range Okay, of what is acceptable, particularly if.
**Susan Daniels**: you're working for something that's pretty precise Okay, then you want to try to have a range or a tolerance for voice acceptable, but if there's things that are.
**Susan Daniels**: More narrative or ambiguous, then you want to try to have standards or opposite ways to observe and assess that that was well done.
**Susan Daniels**: Quality audits okay.
**Susan Daniels**: If you are inspecting or your your monitor all quality i'm sorry quality audits okay are conducted by the project manager, for the most part, or the project managers team now quality audits are not the same as inspections.
**Susan Daniels**: Those two are often confused quality inspections are looking at the end result and inspecting it against the measures okay it's sort of like a microscope did it meet the exact measures quality audits are your auditing your plan you're making sure that you're getting these.
**Susan Daniels**: Inspections you're getting these performance reports you're you're getting them on the deliverables inspected and verified your quality audit is you making sure that you're getting the information you need.
**Susan Daniels**: in a timely manner, to ensure that your project deliverables are on track and meeting the overall quality expectations.
**Susan Daniels**: It is sort of a quality is monitoring and controlling your plan for quality will be another way to put it okay.
**Susan Daniels**: If you're not conducting quality audits okay and you're just running on trust factor.
**Susan Daniels**: It could get pretty late into your project before you start hearing that you're getting crap produced okay or you're getting very low scrap and rework produced so it's important on a regular cadence to have.
**Susan Daniels**: Your kind of audit your plan and making sure that people are performing the way that you've written into your plan for it to be done Okay, does it cost, yes, it costs but that's what you've built into your total budget.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm gonna see what's going on yeah lazy Susan and probably better with no damage inflicted right, so you instead of getting super Sally you get lazy Susan i'll use that in the future, thank you i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan how.
**Susan Daniels**: inspect the product i'm audit the process, thank you Norman Thank you that really crystallizes it you're inspecting a product or result Okay, but you're auditing a process of making sure that quality measures and inspections and performance reports are coming into you and.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm just looking at the on the chat for the moment.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i've got from James, meaning a direct line of authority between the project manager over the quality assurance to maintain control of standards or quality assurance may be standalone so it may not be.
**Susan Daniels**: that's true that happens on in very large sophisticated organizations, there are quality assurance teams, they exist that's their purpose okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And unless the project manager has a you know, like a dotted line of authority over the assigned quality assurance person for your project.
**Susan Daniels**: um they may or may not put the due diligence in that you expect right they may just move things along and let some quality aspect aspect slip.
**Susan Daniels**: On interpretations of the standards boy this sounds like somebody really got some lessons learned and some more stories here yeah sorry James that you have had to deal with that, but it's very true so great on flag to share.
**Susan Daniels**: You want to try to identify who's going to be your quality assurance person on your team and.
**Susan Daniels**: How about Elisa dotted line authority over them because whose reputations at risk they might get ending, and you know but there's still going to.
**Susan Daniels**: have their job and they're going to still be part of what they do, but you your reputation is on scope schedule cost and quality, so this is an area we really focus on OK.
**Susan Daniels**: OK.
**Susan Daniels**: So this is a nice video on cost of quality and then we're going to get into quality control techniques okay some you may be familiar with some not so much so give me a minute to move this over and to data, starting at 413 Okay, so we do cost to quality.
**Susan Daniels**: They aren't being utilized to their full potential, and that is considered and I take it to 413 give me a minute i'm looking at something really small.
**Susan Daniels**: Word deliverable let's explore this concept, a little bit further there's a relationship between quality assurance and quality control.
**Susan Daniels**: Think of quality assurance or QA as what happens in the kitchen of the restaurant.
**Susan Daniels**: Hopefully, the food is being stored properly employees are washing their hands and following food preparation processes.
**Susan Daniels**: and experienced employee will also know how to assemble the plates efficiently and take the time to properly wash and sanitize the dishes.
**Susan Daniels**: If all of the QA procedures are followed properly, it should result in a good quality control or QC result with the deliverables.
**Susan Daniels**: Customers should be able to count on good food quality health standards being met consistency of the menu items efficient service and clean plates and tableware.
**Susan Daniels**: So identifying and following the correct processes in QA should lead to acceptable deliveries and QC but it doesn't always work this way.
**Susan Daniels**: There may be times that you do everything correctly, but you still encounter problems.
**Susan Daniels**: If you have the right conformance activities in place, you should be able to identify problems through prevention activities such as inspections.
**Susan Daniels**: But sometimes problems are found through failure or non conformance when the customer brings it to your attention.
**Susan Daniels**: In this example, a customer has pointed out that they receive their meal on a dirty plate you apologize and offer to replace the meal, at no charge.
**Susan Daniels**: Maybe the customers happy, but you know that on the scale of cost of quality, this is external failure and it's the most expensive of all the cost of quality.
**Susan Daniels**: It also includes the greatest customer exposure you can't keep running your restaurant this way because eventually you'll go out of business.
**Susan Daniels**: You have to find a way to get back into conformance and prevention, what do you think you can do.
**Susan Daniels**: If you said that you'd like to find the cause of the problem and fix it that's perfect going from non conformance back to conformance first requires figuring out what went wrong.
**Susan Daniels**: A great quality tool for this is called the fish bone or issue cow a diagram It can also be called the cause and effect diagram.
**Susan Daniels**: The point is to figure out why the dish was dirty isn't an equipment issue training issue, or is it something else.
**Susan Daniels**: In an issue cow a diagram a lot of times the M word, such as methods machines or materials are common to manufacturing.
**Susan Daniels**: The words that start with P, such as place procedure or people may be common and marketing and the S words like skills suppliers or systems may be common in service.
**Susan Daniels**: You can certainly customize your ishikawa diagram as appropriate, for your industry, the point is to try to identify the cause of a defect.
**Susan Daniels**: An issue how a diagram is known as a fish bone diagram because the possible causes form the shape of the fish bones, and the defects sits in the head of the fish.
**Susan Daniels**: Usually, a cause and effect cause and effect relationship is one to one find and fix the cause and you'll fix the problem but not every situation is that straightforward.
**Susan Daniels**: What if it seems like everything is going wrong, perhaps the defects are in every aspect of the project.
**Susan Daniels**: If you owned this restaurant, you might be tempted to shut down and quit the business altogether.
**Susan Daniels**: But there's actually a tool that can help you in this situation and the good news is that things aren't always as bad as they may seem.
**Susan Daniels**: let's explore a tool that you can use when it seems like your project is full of chaos, the pareto diagram follows an 8020 rule feel free to parade oh wasn't.
**Susan Daniels**: you'll always pay for quality and your projects, either by doing things right, the first time and building quality into the product or after the fact, because something fails.
**Susan Daniels**: conformance is when you build quality in, and this includes both prevention and appraisal.
**Susan Daniels**: let's say you own a restaurant through prevention you train your employees document processes, so that everyone follows them consistently.
**Susan Daniels**: You make sure the equipment is maintained on a regular basis, and you make sure that the project team doesn't skip steps.
**Susan Daniels**: On the scale of costs and customer exposure prevention is the lowest.
**Susan Daniels**: On the appraisal side you can perform testing and inspections in the restaurant, this may mean that the chef taste test each batch of product before it served.
**Susan Daniels**: destructive testing is when you have to break something or use it in order to make sure that it meets quality standards.
**Susan Daniels**: This happens most often in manufacturing, so if you're a cell phone manufacturer, you can determine if a cell phone can be dropped from a certain height without breaking.
**Susan Daniels**: Or if it can be submerged in water, without being damaged, so the cost of conformance consists of all the costs incurred, to ensure that the product conforms to the required level of quality.
**Susan Daniels**: Next we'll talk about the cost of non conformance This consists of all the costs incurred when the product fails to meet the required level of quality.
**Susan Daniels**: The cost of conformance contains two categories of costs, internal and external failure, also known as the cost of poor quality.
**Susan Daniels**: Internal failure costs are those that you catch before they get into the hands of the customer.
**Susan Daniels**: But they're still expensive because you have to scrap all of the work product that was created the wrong way and spend your time doing it again.
**Susan Daniels**: This is also known as rework so if the chef in the restaurant realizes that a batch of soup is way too salty and can't be served to customers.
**Susan Daniels**: it's good that the mistake was caught, but the soup has to be thrown away and cooked again.
**Susan Daniels**: External failure costs are in the hands of the customer, which is the worst situation for quality.
**Susan Daniels**: It has the highest level of cost and customer exposure, this can include needing to warranty a product that has broken or a malfunction and liability if anybody gets hurt.
**Susan Daniels**: In the restaurant industry, this could mean serving a meal, that is undercooked or on a dirty dish and the customer is the one who has to bring it to your attention.
**Susan Daniels**: you'll probably want to apologize and give the customer, a free meal, but that might not stop the customer from expressing their unhappiness.
**Susan Daniels**: or sharing the bad experience on social media, the customer and anyone they share the incident with may not come back to your restaurant.
**Susan Daniels**: You could lose reputation, which in these days of social media can be a very public and embarrassing ordeal.
**Susan Daniels**: It seems pretty clear that the cost of non conformance is one that we want to avoid.
**Susan Daniels**: So why wouldn't project teams invest more in prevention and appraisal it's likely, because the results of good quality prevention aren't very exciting or visible.
**Susan Daniels**: Good prevention means nothing will happen certainly failure gets our attention that's why taking the time to be purposeful about quality.
**Susan Daniels**: is the only way, you can be sure that the time and energy will be spent in conformance activities.
**Susan Daniels**: One activity that teams can perform on the conformance side is a quality audit an audit is a structured independent review that is conducted to determine if activities comply with policies processes and procedures.
**Susan Daniels**: And to identify inefficiencies audits can be scheduled or random and they can be conducted internally or externally an audit examines the way the work is being done, and not necessarily the deliverable itself.
**Susan Daniels**: As a customer of a restaurant, maybe you go there to order your favorite meal.
**Susan Daniels**: A quality audit has nothing to do with that meal or the deliverable audits are all about what goes on in the kitchen and how that meal is prepared.
**Susan Daniels**: generally good conformance in the kitchen should result in a better deliverable let's explore this concept, a little bit on conformance this.
**Susan Daniels**: I just want to say thank you for the alert um I caught the fourth 13 but didn't catch the first part, so thank you appreciate you guys working with me on that.
**Susan Daniels**: So the next segment that we're going to talk about is controlling quality and what kind of tools can we use to control quality.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, some of these we've already cat we've talked about we've already talked about the data gathering tools which can be checklist or samplings raise surveys.
**Susan Daniels**: we've looked at data analysis, which is an art form in itself there's whole divisions that are dedicated to our analytics.
**Susan Daniels**: And of course data representation we'll talk about some of these cause and effect diagrams control charts histograms a scatter grants we'll talk about this shortly so.
**Susan Daniels**: One of the ways that questions can be organized under control quality is do you recognize the different types of tools and what you use them for do you use them to gather to analyze or to communicate and represent the data so we're going to talk about the data gathering tools.
**Susan Daniels**: This line just basically list things and I think you're already very familiar with.
**Susan Daniels**: questionnaires surveys checklist okay checklists are used just to see how often or how frequently something occurs okay you're capturing frequency over time of an event okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Statistical sampling we use that to try to extrapolate whether something is like a good batch or a bad batch right we don't want to.
**Susan Daniels**: test 100% of all of the products so we'll get a statistically valid sample and then just extrapolate or assume that it is representative of the rest of them in that batch.
**Susan Daniels**: So one of the upsides and downsides the upside is statistical sampling is that it's less expensive than testing every single one.
**Susan Daniels**: But the downside is, we can get false positives and we can get false negatives if we've run a batch of something, and we take the last 10 out of that batch.
**Susan Daniels**: It may be that we've just caught the tail end of the good ones and we could have that you know it not represent what's actually happening if we.
**Susan Daniels**: get a bad set it may be representative of the rest of them so it's just not 100% reliable, but it is more cost effective.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: When we're talking about data analysis, we have two different tools that we often we use.
**Susan Daniels**: Frequently so again, the way the questions are organized are do you recognize what the tools are, and do you recognize what they're used for so we just covered examples and data gathering now we're getting into examples of data analysis.
**Susan Daniels**: We have on years of experience of either reading or helping to produce performance on reports, so we have set up as part of our plan of part of our quality management plan to have these different report sent to us that the.
**Susan Daniels**: Processes being.
**Susan Daniels**: audited and that the results are being inspected and we're getting the results back Okay, and this is how we're monitoring that or delivering ultimately a satisfactory high quality result i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um I know it's getting close to the hour, I do want to mention that there is a survey that we're going to ask you to complete at the end.
**Susan Daniels**: i'll talk about this again, but if you, for some reason need to leave early, please take a moment to complete the survey.
**Susan Daniels**: Are we do we improve the experience for you from over yesterday, have you on are you finding this engaging are you are the examples relevant.
**Susan Daniels**: Are you enjoying the videos is this overall give us some feedback on tonight on today's experience you'll seeing the link go through now.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um so i'm going to finish up and at your convenience, please try to give us feedback we only had about 280 responses yesterday um I would really love to have more there's over 100 of you guys in this.
**Susan Daniels**: This cohort so please help us give the optimum experience for you okay um so we can't offer perfect.
**Susan Daniels**: But are we meeting expectations and, in some ways, exceeding your expectations.
**Susan Daniels**: On do want to give a shout out to our the mentoring team, this is not just me and, as you can see.
**Susan Daniels**: A lot of your questions are being filled in by mentors so definitely please give a shout out to them for the support they're providing this they make this thing possible they really do, and I am totally grateful to them.
**Susan Daniels**: Without little commercial is segue set aside.
**Susan Daniels**: Performance reviews.
**Susan Daniels**: Just really know you've got to have them set up in place as part of your master plan who's going to report what to you by when and and what template and what format okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now we watched a little video i'm kind of unplanned the touched on the root cause analysis okay it touched on the arm.
**Susan Daniels**: Basically, the cause and effect okay well okay i'm sorry root cause analysis, we can use like a female right which is on failure management.
**Susan Daniels**: Failure modes and effects analysis all right you've got fish bone you got parade oh you've got scattered diagrams, these are all helping us to see whether we are if we change something is it going to get to the root cause of why we're having a quality variance.
**Susan Daniels**: He had an illustration on the video.
**Susan Daniels**: Here again, on a slide so are you thinking that maybe knowing what an issue call a fish bone root cause diagram is going to be important.
**Susan Daniels**: yeah it is um I would say, there is a high statistical chance that have all the tools and techniques that are going to come through in the questions, knowing how to to use and identify and recognize.
**Susan Daniels**: what's called an issue cow a diagram it's named after the gentleman who invented it.
**Susan Daniels**: But that got kind of hard to say in some languages, so it kind of got to be known as a fish bone Okay, because it's sort of like this is the head of the fish.
**Susan Daniels**: which are basically and this slide tells you an example of a root cause analysis.
**Susan Daniels**: You walk in the room, you draw a straight line you say what the product quality issue is right and then each line is it the equipment, the process, the people, the material, the environment or the management, these are the standard bones of.
**Susan Daniels**: A ishikawa and then you go around the room and you systematically go, could the driver of the defects that we are seeing come from our equipment.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, if so, what could what could be a cause of that right, could it be something related to our process design what could be causes.
**Susan Daniels**: Is there something on a relative to our people and you see how this is done, you.
**Susan Daniels**: You have a structured conversation, instead of just you know, everybody saying not my fault not my fault right are pointing it other people, you have a very visual way to have a.
**Susan Daniels**: Objectively designed conversation about things that where people might feel defensive.
**Susan Daniels**: And when you walk in the room, you might want to say i'm not here to fix the blame i'm here to fix the problem let's get to the root causes of the problems that we're seeing.
**Susan Daniels**: and set the stage that you're not here to try to fix plane that's not relevant okay blame will get figured out later by other people, not your job, not your problem.
**Susan Daniels**: just get to what is the root cause here to fix the problem, this is a wonderful tool if you're not familiar with it please add it to your arsenal or to your tool chest.
**Susan Daniels**: other ways of trying to see if there is a correlation it says a graph that shows relationship between two variables Well, this is really about trying to show a correlation between two things works well in manufacturing or other production environments okay.
**Susan Daniels**: When you have a process and it's it's flowing along and all of a sudden it kind of gets out of compliance and you try to fix something you want to see if what you changed in the process has a direct correlation to way, the process is running okay.
**Susan Daniels**: There aren't multiple examples of scattered diagrams, but please put in your notes learn how to read scatter diagrams, particularly if you are drawn to manufacturing okay or production environments call centers.
**Susan Daniels**: Claims adjudication for healthcare.
**Susan Daniels**: Transactions relative to banking okay if you're in sort of that production work or production environment.
**Susan Daniels**: scatter diagram is are definitely used if you're not and you're just taking the test, you still need to know what one looks like and be able to read, whether there is correlation indicated or not indicated, so there are indirect okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Indirect correlations direct correlations and then you'll see a wavy line and that's called periodic our interval correlations.
**Susan Daniels**: Aerospace engineering, yes, a B testing, yes, thank you for the examples that are coming through.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh, can I repeat that i'm not here to fix the blame i'm here to fix the problem OK.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, another kind of chart that you need to be familiar with is a control chart okay and understanding what the different elements of a control chart are.
**Susan Daniels**: If you were shown, something that looks highly similar okay to this, the new testing environment for the plp.
**Susan Daniels**: Now allows you to point to things are called hotspot answers, so you might be asked and i'm making this up, but you might be asked to identify on just this diagram okay.
**Susan Daniels**: What are the specification limits, and that would be the outer ones, the outer bands, that means.
**Susan Daniels**: Whatever is produced the results okay must fall within these limits to meet the specifications and qualify okay to be to be the result that we need okay is.
**Susan Daniels**: It qualifies is it needs to specifications, but we don't want things to get so far that they fall outside that the specifications before we know it, so we set these control limits sort of guard rails, if you will okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So that if it hits the control in it we're certainly alarm and alerted to start looking at this before it truly calibrates out.
**Susan Daniels**: Of the specification limits Okay, so their internal control limits are really guard rails or alerts levels Okay, called the control limits there's an upper and a lower control him it just like an operator lower specification limit.
**Susan Daniels**: The Center line okay is target, this is the mean this is where we want all of it to average, this is our target result the the optimal Okay, is this line.
**Susan Daniels**: Now you will recognize that the results, often go up and down, which is pretty much the way any result will be when you're reading a control chart result okay it's going to go up and down above and below the arm the Center line because.
**Susan Daniels**: The universe, has a natural rhythm a sine wave Okay, and you expect results to follow up a simple sine wave, but we may experience some things that would cause it to calibrate consistently running, I wonder if we're doing the seven Dec the seven ah i'm not seeing.
**Susan Daniels**: The last seven.
**Susan Daniels**: Please put in your notes, you may need to be aware of, if you get seven points in a row that are either below or above Okay, the control limit.
**Susan Daniels**: is still considered out of control, because things don't just consistently run it will in level.
**Susan Daniels**: Not when you have a process that is the natural rhythm of things so something starting to consistently below the line or consistently above the line that's called a run.
**Susan Daniels**: And when you have seven points doing that you consider it out of control, which means alert has been triggered Okay, and you need to go look into what is the driver of that.
**Susan Daniels**: If you have seven points that goes straight up or seven points to go straight down that is called a trend.
**Susan Daniels**: And you need to be alerted as well to look at what's going on, because your process is calibrating out or calibrating out of control, towards the lower limit or out of control, towards the upper limit.
**Susan Daniels**: But knowing how to read control charts is part of the test.
**Susan Daniels**: Another data representation, you need to be familiar with is something called a parade oh chart Okay, this is where you take 100% of the drivers for the variances that you're seeing.
**Susan Daniels**: You have a variance, what can you look at all the drivers and you divided into you know you organize the drivers and you put the drivers.
**Susan Daniels**: Across the bottom Okay, and you put what percent Okay, are what what number, how many of your defects can be attributed to this particular driver.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, what makes it a parade chart is that we put the drivers in descending order and we make sure we account for 100% of all of the defects.
**Susan Daniels**: By the drivers that we have listed okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Why we use parade oh charts is because we want leadership to immediately notice.
**Susan Daniels**: What are the primary drivers of the defects and where we're going to spend our energy and what we need to do to try to fix it Okay, it is a histogram that is organized in such a way that you're from an A descending order.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so we've reached the end of the slides that we have for.
**Susan Daniels**: The curriculum, we have a couple of mastery questions, so what i'm going to do is.
**Susan Daniels**: I find that it may be more helpful to to work with the questions that are coming through the Q amp a because there are real questions that people have a top of mine so i'm going to spend a moment.
**Susan Daniels**: To see if we've got some good questions and then we'll spend the last five minutes really just talking about some of the.
**Susan Daniels**: The master builders that we have.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, is there ever a scenario where the control line, maybe to to provide space for variance um.
**Susan Daniels**: You have the control limit and the specification limit So yes, we basically still have a little bit of variance available that's but we're still significantly away from our target line, and we need to be definitely alerted and responsive before it gets above the specification line okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Are there are these charts are these charts are applicable applicable for agile as well.
**Susan Daniels**: um if we're trying to um if we've done a a product, you know we've done a spread and we're trying to get through the definition of done and we're trying to.
**Susan Daniels**: verify the result right before we DEMO it before we go to take it, how to house and show it to the customer, we may use some of these quality control.
**Susan Daniels**: measures and tools and techniques to try to identify what the root cause of why there's a bug why it's not running why it's not working so Yes, some of these tools can be used in an agile environment, but it will be used.
**Susan Daniels**: At the juncture point where we're trying to verify definition of done that everything works before we release it to the sprint review and to the customer for feedback So yes, they would apply is there ever a scenario where the control line, again we did that one um.
**Susan Daniels**: There, there is one Center line to control lines and to specification limits on control charts that's the way it goes, you will not have to control limits if that was the earlier question i'm agreeing with Carl I may have missed on interpreted the question okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Would a tornado diagram be useful in conjunction with these charts i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: tornado diagrams I have seen used when we are looking at risks for probability and impact so i'm not seeing tornado diagrams be aligned to quality.
**Susan Daniels**: has been my experience, particularly in all of the curriculums that i've been teaching So if I had a choice of tornado diagram I would associate that with risk management and not quality management, but there may be some creative application i've not aware of.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um what is a sprint sprint is the name of an iteration or a time box, that is used in agile.
**Susan Daniels**: project management methodology.
**Susan Daniels**: I asked the question wrong okay i'm into to Center lines to allow, for there is no, you will not have to Center lines, you would have target that's the way control charts are designed okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Thanks Stephen for helping Jason on that one okay so.
**Susan Daniels**: I do want you to put in your notes to look up trends runs rule of seven.
**Susan Daniels**: relative to project management controlling quality okay you put those sort of words into a search on the pmi website, or you look at some of the YouTube videos on controlling quality, you are bound to get a lot of information on those those concepts okay.
**Susan Daniels**: um can a SWOT analysis be useful, yes, but that's.
**Susan Daniels**: The strengths weaknesses opportunities and threats, this is usually not a tool that is used with quality SWOT analysis on that.
**Susan Daniels**: That might be again that's that's not out a quality tool okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Can I repeat what to search for trends that's where you have seven points running up or down on a control chart runs things are running parallel to the control line trends runs rule of seven okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You can find control charts here great calm Carl really appreciate it okay i'm going to wrap up with some mastery questions.
**Susan Daniels**: OK and i'm going to ask you, on once again, please take the time to get us your feedback is very important.
**Susan Daniels**: Are you finding value in me going above and beyond what's just written on the slides Am I expanding upon the concepts giving illustrations.
**Susan Daniels**: Am I on giving examples that are helpful is this more than just which you could do, reading the slides yourself right you wanted a live instructor experience, are you getting the value add that you're looking for so so please provide some feedback and let us know.
**Susan Daniels**: Your your experience and your impression of my instruction and facilitation Okay, what is the process to create a project budget you guys are already going for answers, and I am seeing very much a consensus okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Here we go and the answer is, of course, that's why we took the time to to look at that chart how we read it from left to right can we build all of the activities, the activities, then go to the work packages and then you just keep building it up, adding your contingencies and.
**Susan Daniels**: i've got to request Carl for the survey link again you if you have the ability to scroll back through the chat, but if you don't have the arm.
**Susan Daniels**: The the ability to heal he can add it in when we get done with the master builders which of the following is the correct definition of the critical path.
**Susan Daniels**: Oh Thank you everyone who's on putting that the link back in you guys are great you're a great group really appreciate the peer to peer support getting those.
**Susan Daniels**: Those links back in.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay again i'm seeing a lot of consensus on what the right answer is, at the end all right for this one and you're right Okay, the critical path is the longest path through the network, which represents the shortest time in which the project can be completed.
**Susan Daniels**: Well done well done.
**Susan Daniels**: Your company is designing a game for families to start whether the game is easy enough for children, the team creates a prototype and then establishes test criteria.
**Susan Daniels**: Then the team establishes test groups of 200 children specific age group and 50 different schools and 30 locations, the prototype will then be modified and rolled out across the country What are they doing when they're bringing all these people together.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: What are they engaged in with okay and creating prototypes and getting feedback okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So they've got this prototype and they're giving it to a segment of the population Okay, what do you think they're trying what kind of tools do you think they're using.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're right okay you're right there taking a statistical sampling of their target audience and getting their feedback on just the prototype.
**Susan Daniels**: Right, this is the using an iterative approach to their their product development.
**Susan Daniels**: they're going to do the prototype then they're going to do another get the feedback to another release get some feedback to another release right so they're getting, but at this point they're doing statistical sampling.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so.
**Susan Daniels**: I again want to thank you for today and for your full engagement.
**Susan Daniels**: it's been where we've gone deep on only four topics, the next time we're together we're going to cover quite a few different topics, so you know have your pencil ready because there's going to be a lot of top of changes that we're doing.
**Susan Daniels**: And I am excited that to be working with you on this boot camp and I look forward to joining you tomorrow, thank you, thank you all and i'm going to say good night I will go ahead and say we're done and.
**Susan Daniels**: Again, thank you for all the thank yous I appreciate that i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: good night all it's the top of the hour.
see if I can.